logan lerman Azra miller had a baby and
they made Logan Miller so that's me
everyone else here hi guys oh hey how
are you going we're gonna be talking
about the good neighbor the good
neighbor
starring Logan Miller cure Gilchrist and
the beautiful James God me and Kier we
play these two teenagers named Sean
Ethan and we're very highly intelligent
and we decide to have this documentary
where we follow around this old man who
lives near me his name is Harold rainy
and we believe that he potentially
murdered his wife and so we want to get
down to the bottom of it
and we do so by creating this haunting
experience for him to make him believe
that a ghost is lurking inside of his
house but little do we know that all of
these secrets start unraveling and we
get to find out what grainy really is
and what happens when you push somebody
to the first for this level of shame and
agony I think my character Ethan he is a
bit sociopathic and he goes about this
completely in the wrong way but he does
it just for some validation and to get
his name out there and be respected
James Caan James what's he like oh my
god he is as crazy as he's ever depicted
himself we debuted a clip yesterday no
I'm sorry it's just like yeah the few
seconds that he's even in that clip is
so intense
cuz the next time if it happens again
I'm like caught him in four pieces and
said a moment his chance that one is
like a sheer threat and you think like
Oh something is messed up with this guy
is there something messed up with him I
guess you gotta see the movie to guess
you gotta see it and find out you guys
can go and see the good neighbor in
select theaters and on VOD nationwide